the United States ran up big debts
during the global financial crisis in
the recession in the aftermath trying to
stimulate the economy and make sure that
we didn't deep dive into an even deeper
recession than where we already were
that makes sense because if you're in
the middle of a downturn it's not a good
time to put on the brakes with fiscal
austerity raising taxes to raise more
money and cutting spending to tighten
the government's belt it especially
doesn't make sense if you can borrow at
low interest rates and during the recent
crisis the United States could borrow at
some of the lowest interest rates in its
history and that's why our debt problem
is not as urgent as a lot of people may
say right now the debt service that we
pay that's the interest payments that we
pay all the time are at a very low rate
in fact they were much higher during the
Reagan and first Bush administration's
this may not last forever because
interest rates can rise just as they can
fall and if interest rates do rise which
typically happens when the economy
recovers and there's more demand for
credit then we will have to start paying
a little bit more and we'll have to
start thinking more about how we're
going to close that big debt gap we have
several years before that happens though
so we can phase in a nice gradual
solution without making any sharp cuts
to spending and without making any sharp
increases in tax rates but over the long
term there's no doubt we need to cut
spending a little bit and we need to
have higher tax rates because right now
we have some of the lowest effective tax
rates since the 1940s and at a time when
people expect more than ever from their
government will have to deal with Social
Security and Medicare to but we
typically do that by extending the
retirement age a little bit cutting
benefits a little bit and maybe we'll
even remove benefits from some higher
earners all of these things together
will help us to close our debt gap but
we don't have to do it in a sharp
shocking way today we have a few years
of runway to do it it's definitely not a
good idea just to kick the can down the
road and let the next government deal
with it it's tempting to do that because
people in this government are more
concerned about re-election than what
might happen 10 or 20 years from now but
we can use the time that we have to
phase in these changes so that there
aren't abrupt dislocations in our
economy a responsible Congress would act
now setting a plan that will fade is
phasing these changes
over the next five to ten years